norway ms a rich country it has a
trillion dollars in the bank so to say
that money was made from the country's
vast oil reserves and Norway's sovereign
wealth fund has become one of the
largest single investors around the
world but now the Norwegians have
discovered their green conscience and
have decided to pull many of its
investments from companies who make
their money with well oil and other
fossil fuels that's a massive
endorsement of green energy one could
think but environmentalists are not
happy the aim of Norway's sovereign
wealth fund is to ensure responsible
management of the revenue from the
country's oil and natural gas sales for
the benefit of current and future
generations so what does responsible
management mean the funds investments
have become a topic of heated debate the
Norwegian Parliament has barred the fund
from owning stakes in a range of arms
tobacco and fossil fuel firms it has had
to sell holdings in hundreds of
companies in a major divestment
initiative some of those companies are
coal producers either miners or power
producers based on coal and for those
ethical reasons close to 70 coal
producers or coal companies have been
excluded from the fountain that was in
2014
environmental activists at first
welcomed the divestment by such a major
player as a significant move towards
responsible sustainable investing but
some are now saying that it's premature
for politicians to talk up the funds
green credentials given that there's
still such a long way to go the
Norwegian government here is speaking
with two tongues the Norwegian Prime
Minister was telling last on the 24th of
May while speaking in front of the
climate striking school kids that what
they that what the Norwegian government
has done since the previous school
strike was actually to divest 134 oil
companies from the the state-owned
puncheon pension fund she's talking
about this in climate terms
and and one could ask who is actually
the boss and the person in charge here
Environmental Protection may indeed be a
concern but the funds core mandate is to
preserve the wealth of the Norwegian
people if the world turns away from
fossil fuels holdings in those
industries could collapse in value we
are not aiming to send a message to the
world we are aiming to take good care of
the region people's savings and the aim
of this process has been to reduce the
overall oil price risk in Norwegian
economy and that's that really this one
is not an instrument of the inn or
environment or environmental policy it's
not an instrument of our foreign policy
it's it's a financial instrument to take
care of Norwegian people savings the
sovereign wealth fund has far fewer coal
companies in its portfolio now but it's
keeping stakes and controversial fossil
fuel giants like Exxon Chevron and
Halliburton still involved in oil and
natural gas exploration